IN AN EVENLY DIVIDED SENATE.
CHRIS.
>> Chris: DAVID, THANK YOU.
AND JOINING US NOW, THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY,
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS.
MR. SECRETARY, WELCOME TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY"."
>> Secretary Mayorkas: GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME, CHRIS.
>> Chris: I WANT TO START WITH
SOMETHING THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY JEN PSAKI SAID THIS
WEEK.
TAKE A LOOK, SIR.
>> WE ARE TAKING STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN KIDS COME TO THE
BORDER, WE LOOK TO SEE IF THEY
HAVE A PHONE NUMBER IN MY POCKET
SO WE CAN CALL THE FAMILY MEMBER
AND GET THEM TO THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> Chris: I UNDERSTAND
COMPASSION FOR THESE CHILDREN,
BUT WHY IS IT THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE U.S. TO RESETTLE MINORS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY?
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
THAT IS THE LAW UNDER THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE AN ASYLUM PROGRAM THAT
RECOGNIZES YOUNG CHILDREN,
YOUNG, VULNERABLE CHILDREN’S
RIGHT TO CLAIM ASYLUM, TO CLAIM
FEAR FROM PERSECUTION BY REASON
OF THEIR MEMBERSHIP IN A
PARTICULAR GROUP.
THAT IS WHAT THE LAW PROVIDES
AND WE ADMINISTER AND ENFORCE
THOSE LAWS.
>> Chris: YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TALK ABOUT BEING
HUMANE, BUT LET’S GO BACK TO
WHAT THE TRUMP POLICY WAS, WHICH
IN THE CASE OF NONMEXICAN
MINORS, WAS NOT, AS HAS BEEN
SUGGESTION, SIMPLY TO TURN THESE
KIDS ALONE DON’T MAKE AROUND AND
PUT THEM BACK INTO THE DESERT.
IN FACT WE WOULD COORDINATE WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES, WE WERE CHARTER
PLANES, WE WOULD SEND THEM BACK
BY AIRPLANE TO RESETTLE WITH
THEIR FAMILIES.
WHY IS IT MORE HUMANE TO TAKE
THESE KIDS, TO PUT THEM IN
BORDER PATROL FACILITIES THAT
WERE NOT MEANT FOR CHILDREN,
OFTEN TIMES FOR MANY MORE DAYS
THAN THE LEGAL LIMIT?
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION DID.
YOU’LL FORGIVE ME.
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION DID
EXPEL CHILDREN, DID FLY CHILDREN
TO COUNTRIES WHERE -- FROM WHICH
THEY WERE FLEEING, COUNTRIES
THAT DID NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO ADMINISTER ASYLUM CLAIMS,
COUNTRIES THAT SUFFER TREMENDOUS
VIOLENCE, POVERTY, CORRUPTION,
AND OTHER INFIRMITIES, SO TO
SUGGEST THAT THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION HANDLED THE NEEDS
OF CHILDREN IN A HUMANE WAY IS
JUST FALSE.
>> Chris: WELL, YOU SEEM TO
HAVE AGREED WITH ME, SIR, THAT
THEY WOULD PUT THEM ON PLANES.
THEY WOULDN’T JUST SEND THEM
BACK OVER THE DESERT, THEY WOULD
PUT THEM ON A PLANE AND FLY THEM
BACK TO GUATEMALA OR EL SALVADOR
EL SALVADOR.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT EVERY
MINOR -- THE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF MINORS COMING
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY HAS A
LEGITIMATE ASYLUM CLAIM AND THAT
A LOT OF THEM ARE JUST COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE HERE
IN AMERICA WHICH IS
UNDERSTANDABLE, BUT ISN’T
NECESSARILY OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
WE ADMINISTER OUR LAWS AND LET
ME SAY A FEW THINGS, IF I MAY.
NUMBER ONE, THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION DISMANTLED THE
ORDERLY AND SAFE WAY THAT THESE
CHILDREN COULD MAKE THEIR CLAIMS
CLAIMS.
IT TORE DOWN THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN MINORS PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWED THESE CHILDREN TO MAKE
THEIR CLAIMS UNDER UNITED STATES
LAW WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE THE
PERILOUS JOURNEY.
WE ARE REBUILDING THAT PROCESS.
WE ARE ENCOURAGING FAMILIES NOT
TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN ALONG THE
DANGEROUS JOURNEY, BECAUSE SO
MANY DO NOT MAKE IT SAFELY.
WE ARE ENCOURAGING THEM NOT TO
DO SO.
YET IF THEY ARRIVE AT THE
BORDER, WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO ALLOW THEM TO MAKE THEIR
CLAIMS UNDER UNITED STATES LAW
AND TO ADDRESS -- THESE ARE
VULNERABLE CHILDREN -- TO
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS, AND WE CAN
DO SO IN A SAFE AND ORDERLY
MANNER.
IT TAKES TIME BECAUSE THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM WAS DISMANTLED.
WE ARE WORKING ON IT AND WE WILL
SUCCEED BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE
DO.
>> Chris: I’M GOING TO GET
BACK TO THAT IN A MOMENT,
MR. SECRETARY, BUT THE DAY AFTER
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK OFFICE, HE
MADE THIS PROMISE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: THE
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS AND I AND
OUR ENTIRE ADMINISTRATION WILL
ALWAYS BE HONEST AND TRANSPARENT
WITH YOU ABOUT BOTH THE GOOD
NEWS THE BAD.
>> Chris: SO WHY HAS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REFUSED TO ALLOW
REPORTERS TO SEE FOR THEMSELVES
AND TO RECORD WHAT THE
CONDITIONS ARE UNDER WHICH THESE
MINORS ARE BEING HOUSED?
WHY IN FACT DID YOU, WHEN YOU
WENT TO THE BORDER ON FRIDAY,
AND LED A CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION, WHY DID YOU REFUSE
TO ALLOW REPORTERS TO SEE THE
CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH THESE
MINORS ARE BEING HELD?
>> Secretary Mayorkas: TWO
THINGS, CHRIS, IF I MAY.
NUMBER ONE, LET’S NOT FORGET
THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC AND WE ARE FOCUSED ON
OUR OPERATIONS EXECUTING OUR
OPERATIONS IN A CROWDED BORDER
PATROL FACILITY WHERE HUNDREDS
OF VULNERABLE MIGRANT CHILDREN
ARE LOCATED, NUMBER ONE.
AND NUMBER TWO, WE’RE WORKING ON
PROVIDING FOOTAGE SO THAT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC CAN SEE THE
BORDER PATROL STATIONS AND I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU AND OTHER
REPORTERS TO SEE THE FACILITIES
UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT,
WHERE THOSE CHILDREN ARE
SHELTERED AND WHERE THEY BELONG
AND WHERE WE ARE MOVING THEM AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> Chris: SECRETARY MAYORKAS,
RESPECTFULLY, SIR, I THINK THERE
IS A SAFE CONDITION UNDER WHICH
A POOL CAMERA CREW AND A
REPORTER COULD GO INTO SOME OF
THESE FACILITIES.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR TWO
MONTHS NOW AND REPORT THE
CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH THESE
MINORS ARE BEING HELD, IT SEEMS
TO ME TO SAY IT’S IMPOSSIBLE TO
DO BECAUSE OF COVID SOUNDS LIKE
AN EXCUSE.
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
WE ARE WORKING ON PROVIDING
ACCESS SO THAT INDIVIDUALS WILL
BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT THE
CONDITIONS IN A BORDER PATROL
STATION ARE LIKE, BUT FIRST
THINGS FIRST, WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A PANDEMIC WE ARE
FOCUSED ON OPERATIONS AND
EXECUTING ON OUR PLANS.
THAT’S OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY, BUT
WE ARE PROVIDING MORE ABOUT
ACCESS AND CERTAINLY REPORTERS
CAN SEE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES FACILITIES IN
WHICH CHILDREN ARE SHELTERED FOR
A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
>> Chris: TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT RAISED TWO
CONCERNS THIS WEEK ABOUT
CONDITIONS IN THE CAMP FOR
MINORS IN MIDLAND, TEXAS.
TAKE A LOOK, SIR.
>> SO THERE IS NO BIBLE USABLE
RUNNING WATER AT THE LOCATION IN
MIDLAND AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT,
MORE THAN 10% OF THE MIGRANTS AT
THE MIDLAND LOCATION HAVE NOW
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVID-19.
>> Chris: MR. SECRETARY, WHY
NOT LET REPORTERS GO TO SEE WITH
THE CONDITIONS ARE AT THE CAMP
IN MIDLAND, AND IS IT TRUE THAT
MORE THAN 10% OF THE MINORS IN
MIDLAND HAVE TESTED POSITIVE AND
IN FACT THAT MORE THAN 200
MIGRANTS IN BROWNSVILLE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVERT AND THEN
WERE RELEASED?
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
THE MINORS WHO ARE ARRIVING AND
WHO ARE PLACED IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
FACILITIES ARE TESTED, THEY ARE
ALL TESTED, ISOLATED, AND
QUARANTINE.
OUR COVID-19 PROTOCOLS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ARE
OPERATED VERY EFFICIENTLY.
WE ALSO, I SHOULD SAY, WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH LOCAL OFFICIALS IN
TEXAS, WITH LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
TO ALSO TEST, ISOLATE, AND
QUARANTINE CHILDREN.
AND WE OFFER REIMBURSEMENT,
100%, FROM FEMA AND I DO HOPE
THAT GOVERNOR ABBOTT RECONSIDERS
HIS POSITION OF NOT ALLOWING
THOSE LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO BE REIMBURSED
100% BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT’S ALL IN THE SERVICE OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPERATIVE.
>> Chris: EXCUSE ME, SIR, I
WANT TO PUT UP WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS DONE ON
IMMIGRATION POLICY IN JUST HIS
FIRST TWO MONTHS IN OFFICE.
HE HALTED PART OF TITLE 42 TO
ALLOW UNACCOMPANIED MINORS TO
STAY IN THE U.S. DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
HE ENDED THE PROVISION THAT
ASYLUM-SEEKERS MUST REMAIN IN
MEXICO WHILE THEIR CASES ARE
BEING HEARD AND HE SUSPENDED THE
SAFE THIRD COUNTRY AGREEMENTS TO
SHARE ASYLUM-SEEKERS WITH OTHERS
COUNTRIES.
IT YOU PUT OUT THIS STATEMENT ON
TUESDAY.
"WE ARE ON PACE TO ENCOUNTER
MORE INDIVIDUALS ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER THEN WE HAVE IN
THE LAST 20 YEARS."
MR. SECRETARY, DO YOU NOT SEE A
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE SURGE AT
THE BORDER IN THE POLICY CHANGES
THAT JOE BIDEN HAS MADE IN HIS
FIRST TWO MONTHS?
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
I DO NOT.
BUT I AM SEEING IS THE RESULT,
AND WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THE
RESULT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
DISMANTLEMENT OF THE SAFE AND
ORDERLY IMMIGRATION PROCESSES
THAT WERE BUILT OVER MANY, MANY
YEARS BY PRESIDENTS OF BOTH
PARTIES.
THAT’S WHAT WE ARE SEEING AND
THAT’S WHY IT’S TAKING TIME FOR
US TO EXECUTE OUR PLANS TO
ADMINISTER THE HUMANITARIAN
CLAIMS OF VULNERABLE CHILDREN.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THIS IS ABOUT VULNERABLE
CHILDREN, AND LET ME SAY ONE
THING AS WELL, IF I MAY, CHRIS.
SAFE THIRD COUNTRY AGREEMENTS IS
MISNAMED.
THERE’S NOTHING SAFE ABOUT IT.
TO RETURN PEOPLE TO THE VERY
COUNTRIES FROM WHICH THEY ARE
FLEEING PERSECUTION.
THAT’S JUST FALSE, AND WE HAVE
REPLACED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY WITH A SAFE AND ORDERLY
TRIAGE SYSTEM WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN MEXICO AND
HUMANITARIAN ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE AND WE
ARE NOT EXPELLING VULNERABLE
CHILDREN.
AT THE SAME TIME WE ARE
ENCOURAGING THEM NOT TO TAKE THE
DANGEROUS JOURNEY BECAUSE WE ARE
REBUILDING ORDERLY PROCESSES FOR
THEM AS WELL.
AS OUR COUNTRY HAS ALWAYS HAD
UNTIL THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
>> Chris: ONE FINAL QUESTION,
SIR.
YOU SAY THAT YOU ARE ENCOURAGING
MINORS NOT TO COME ACROSS.
THE MESSAGE CLEARLY ISN’T
GETTING THROUGH.
IT’S TRUE THAT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
BEGAN TO INCREASE IN THE FINAL
MONTHS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, BUT THERE HAS
BEEN A BIG, SHARP SPIKES SINCE
JOE BIDEN HAS COME IN AND I WANT
TO PUT UP SOME OF THE NUMBERS
HERE.
74,000 BORDER APPREHENSIONS IN
TRUMP’S FINAL MONTH, FULL MONTH
OF DECEMBER.
100,000 IN JOE BIDEN’S FIRST
FULL MONTH IN FEBRUARY.
JUST UNDER 5,000 UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS CAME ACROSS THE BORDER,
APPREHENDED IN TRUMP’S FINAL
MONTH OF DECEMBER.
9400 IN DECEMBER -- IN FEBRUARY.
THE NUMBERS ROSE DRAMATICALLY
AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE, AFTER HE CHANGED THE
POLICIES AND IN ADDITION, FOR
ALL YOUR TALK ABOUT MINORS, THE
FACT IS, SIR, ACCORDING TO CBP,
BORDER PATROL NUMBERS, 58.87% OF
THE FAMILY UNITS THAT CAME
ACROSS IN FEBRUARY HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO STAY IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU ARE NOT RETURNING THEM, THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM, BACK
SOUTH OF THE BORDER.
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
A FEW POINTS.
YOU MENTIONED THE NUMBERS BEGAN
TO SPIKE ADMITTEDLY IN THE LAST
COUPLE MONTHS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
ACTUALLY THE NUMBERS BEGAN TO
SPIKE IN APRIL OF 2020.
THE NUMBERS WERE EXTREMELY HIGH
THROUGHOUT 2019.
THIS ADMIN ATTRITION --
>> Chris: NOT LIKE THEY HAVE
BEEN IN FEBRUARY, SIR.
>> Secretary Mayorkas: THE
ARMS OF THEIR PARENTS.
>> Chris: NOT LIKE THEY HAVE
BEEN IN FEBRUARY.
>> Secretary Mayorkas: CHRIS,
WE DO EXPEL FAMILIES.
WE ARE WORKING WITH MEXICO TO
INCREASE MEXICO’S CAPACITY TO
RECEIVE THE EXPELLED FAMILIES.
THE BORDER IS SECURE, THE BORDER
IS CLOSED.
WE’VE BEEN UNEQUIVOCAL IN THAT
AND WE ARE OPERATIONALIZING OUR
PROCESSES, EXECUTING OUR PLANS,
WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS AND WE
TREAT VULNERABLE CHILDREN
HUMANELY.
WE CAN DO IT AND WE ARE DOING
IT.
>> Chris: SECRETARY,
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME THIS WEEK
AND THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING ALL